when you look at the big questions of
humanity of
hate
war
what else is there evil
maybe there's the positive aspects of
that
of meaning of love
um what is the fact that
reality is an illusion
perceived
what what is the conscious realism
when applied to daily life what kind of
impact does it have a lot and it's it's
sort of scary
um
we all know that life is ephemeral
and spiritual traditions have said wake
up to the fact that you know anything
that you do here is going to disappear
but it's even more ephemeral than
perhaps
we have thought i see this bottle
because i create it right now as soon as
i
look away
that data structure has been garbage
collected that bottle
i have to recreate it every time i look
so i spend all my money i buy this fancy
car
that car i have to keep recreating it
every time i look at it it's that
ephemeral
so all the things that we
invest ourselves in we fight over we
kill each other over and we have wars
over
these are all it's just like people in a
virtual reality simulation
right and and there's this this porsche
and we all see the porsche well where
that porsche exists when i look at it i
turn my headset and i look at it
and
and then if joe turns his headset right
he'll see his portion it's not it's not
even the same portion that i see he's
creating his own porsche
so these things are exceedingly
ephemeral and and and now
just imagine saying that that's my
porsche
well you can agree to say that it's your
portion but but really the porsche only
exists as long as you
look
so so this all of a sudden what the
spiritual traditions have been saying
for a long long time this gets cashed
out in in mathematically precise science
it's saying
in femoral yes in fact it lasts for a
few milliseconds a few hundred
milliseconds while you look at it and
then it's gone so so the whole idea
why are we fighting why do we hate
it's
we fight over possessions
because we we think that we're small
little objects
inside this
pre-existing space time we assume that
that that mansion and that car
exists
independent of us and that somehow
we these little things can have our
sense of
self and importance enhanced by having
that special car or that special house
or that special person when in fact
is just the opposite
you create that mansion every time you
look
that's that's you're the you're
something far deeper than that mansion
you're the
entity which can create that mansion on
the fly and there's nothing
there there's nothing to the mansion
except what you create in this moment so
al so all of a sudden
when you take this point of view
it it has all sorts of implications
for how we interact with each other how
how we treat each other
um
and again a lot of things that spiritual
traditions have said
it's a mixed bag spiritual traditions
are a mixed bag so let me just be right
up front about that i'm not promoting
any particular but they do have some
insights yeah they have wisdom they have
certain wisdom they have i can point to
nonsense i won't go into it but i can
also point to lots of nonsense so so the
the issue is to then to look for the key
the key insights and they i think they
have
a lot of insights about
the ephemeral nature of of objects in
space and time and not being attached to
them including our own bodies
and reversing that i'm not this little
thing a little consciousness trapped in
the body and the consciousness itself is
only a product of the body so when the
body dies the consciousness disappears
it turns completely around the
consciousness is fundamental the body
my hand exists right now because i'm
looking at it my hand is gone
i have no hand i have i have no brain i
have no heart if you looked you'll see a
heart
whatever i am
[Music]
is this really complicated thing in
consciousness that's that's what i am
all the stuff that i thought i was
is something that i create on the fly
and delete so this whole so this is
completely
radical restructuring of how we think
about um possessions
about identity
about
survival of death
and and and so forth this is completely
transformative but the nice thing is
that
this whole approach of conscious agents
unlike the spiritual traditions which
have said
in some cases similar things
they set it in precisely
this is mathematics
we can actually now begin to stay
precisely here's the mathematical model
of consciousness conscious agents here's
how it maps onto spacetime which i
should sketch really briefly
and here's why
things are ephemeral
and here's why you shouldn't be worried
about the ephemeral nature of things
because
you're not a little tiny entity inside
space and time
quite the opposite you're the author of
space and time
you